first of all I want to thank my family
my friends the incredible people of
Chicago and all over the country in the
world who have prayed for me who have
supported me who've shown me so much
love no one will ever know how much that
has meant to me and I will forever be
grateful I want you to know that not for
a moment was it in vain
I've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one I would
not be my mother's son if I was capable
of one drop of what I was accused of
this has been an incredibly difficult
time honestly one of the worst of my
entire life
but I am a man of faith and I'm a man
that has knowledge of my history and I
would not bring my family our lives or
the movement through a fire like this
I just wouldn't so I want to thank my
legal counsel from the bottom of my
heart and I would also like to thank the
state of Illinois for attempting to do
what's right now I'd like nothing more
than to just get back to work
and move on with my life but make no
mistakes I will always continue to fight
for the justice and equality and
betterment of marginalized people
everywhere so again thank you for all
the support thank you for faith and
thank you too god bless y'all thank you
very much